[Music]
Frank is a movie that I've been wanting
to see for quite some time it just
finally hit VOD last night and I watched
it at 3 a.m. in the morning on my
PlayStation 3
that's what happens when you don't live
in New York and LA gotta wait awhile for
these type of releases and I was so
excited to watch this movie because it
looks so different and original and that
was something that I was really excited
to see Frank was inspired by Frank
Sidebottom a comedian who wore this
giant mask all the time whenever he
performed in this movie Michael
Fassbender plays that character except
he is a musician and domhnall gleeson is
a keyboardist who kind of gets shoved
into the band by accident because their
keyboardist goes insane and tries to
kill himself so he goes on this journey
with this band who also includes scoot
mcnairy and Maggie Gyllenhaal where
they're trying to create an album but at
the same time movie really isn't about
that it's really about these characters
they're all very odd and damaged people
they all have very strange pasts and
they're all riveting characters and
Frank is one of my favorite movies that
I have seen this year this is a
terrifically original and unique movie I
cannot think of another movie like this
at all I couldn't predict where this
story was going it seems like it's going
in a certain way and you're like okay I
understand where it's going and then it
takes a left turn and goes in a
completely different direction I love
that about this movie I loved watching a
movie where I wasn't able to predict
everything that happened every other
second because this movie was so
different domhnall gleeson in this film
as I said plays a keyboardist but he's
also a songwriter and he's trying to
figure out where he is in life he's
trying to understand his position in
life and he thinks that he's going
somewhere with this band but this movie
really is about Frank played by Michael
Fassbender this is the most interesting
character I've seen in a film this year
because you want to know about him so
badly it's like you are dying to know
more about this guy why does he wear
this mask all the time what is this
character what is his backstory why is
he like this and that's one of the
reasons this movie is so consistently
entertaining because you actually really
do care about these characters and you
want to know more about them you want to
be inside their heads and you're really
are just grasping for knowledge and
information about why these characters
are doing some of the things they do
phos bender is absolutely magnificent in
this movie I think this is one of the
best performances he's ever given
despite the fact that you can't even see
his face
and that is so incredibly impressive
he's also very hilarious in this movie
and this movie is genuinely funny and
that's something that I haven't even
mentioned yet Frank is one of the
funniest movies I've seen so far this
year simply because it understands very
small tendencies in mankind and it's
able to exploit the way that we
sometimes view art or music and it
really gets in the head of a damaged
artist or you know a musician who just
can't figure out what his place is in
life a movie that did that very
similarly last year was inside Llewyn
Davis this movie has more likable and
endearing characters though and there
are times where you are listening to
their music and you're wondering is this
even good and you're trying to figure
out what wavelength these characters are
on and that is one of the greatest
things I can say about this movie is
just those characters I keep saying this
but those characters made this movie so
incredibly entertaining and that's one
of the best ways you can make a good
movie is to have characters that are
entertaining characters that you care
about and that you want to know more
about and this movie has those
characters in spades and a fantastic
lead performance by Michael Fassbender
as well as domhnall gleeson who is very
good in this movie I absolutely adored
the way this movie ended I thought it
was perfect it was beautiful Frank is
one of my favorite movies of the year
and I'm going to give it an a guys it is
available on video on demand right now I
downloaded it from my Vudu app on the
PlayStation Network so if you guys want
to see this movie definitely give it a
chance I strongly recommend it thank you
so much as always for watching guys and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck minimized
you